اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي ملفاتي هذا المساء
في قمم الرياض شراكه نستراتيجيه كامله بين
الرياض وبكين ورئيس الصناعي يقول ان
زيارته فتحت عصرا جديدا للعلاقات مع العرب
وفي موضوعنا الثاني للنقاش شركه طيران
المعراج الايرانيه تنظم رحلات الى مطار
بيروت هل المخاوف من استخدام هذه الرحلات
كما ممر لتهريب الاسلحه لحزب الله في
محلها وما سبلوا مواجهتها
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل وقع الملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز ورئيس الصينيه
الشامله بين البلدين جاء ذلك خلال استقبال
الملك سلمان الرئيس الصيني في قصر اليمامه
برياض حيث جرى خلال اللقاء استعراض علاقات
الصدقه التاريخيه بين السعوديه والصين
وسبل تعذيزها بما يخدم مصالح البلدين
والشعبين الصديقين في شتى المجلات وافدت
وكاله الانباء السعوديه بانه ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان ورئيس
الصيني شهد ايضا عددا من الاتفاقيات
ومذكرات التفاهم بينها باكين والرياضه في
مجالات من بينها الطاقه الهيدروجينيه
وتشجيع الاستثمار المباشر كما بحث ولي
العهد مع الرئيس الصيني فرصه استثمار
الموارد المتاحه في البلدين والمستجدات
الاقليميه والدوليه هذا هو يتواجد القاده
العرب للمشاركه في القمهتين العربيه
خليجيه كما تاتي زياره رئيس الصيني لعقد
ثلاثي قمم لتعزيز التعاون والتنميه بين
الدول المشاركه
[موسيقى]
الشهاده الملف مع ضيوفينا من الرياض عضوا
الاحمر رئيس تحرير العربيه اهلا بك وكذلك
من الرياضه الدكتور محمد فرحات رئيس ومركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه اهلا بكم
الكريمين وسمه حالي ان ابدا معك يا استاذ
عدوان بصفتك رئيس تحرير اكيد بانه تصل
كاعدد مهم من المقالات المراجعتها فان
وصلك مقال يمكن ان يكون معنوا كالاتي
العلاقات السعوديه الصينيه من تبادل تجاري
الى شراك استراتيجيه كامله وان وصلك من
نقاط الاهم التي يجب ان يتضمنها هكذا مقال
اولا شكرا لكم شكرا لك العربيه على
استضافه يعني اعتقد لو وصل مثل هذا المقال
وما هي الابرز النقاط التي يجب ان يتضمن
هذا المقال وهذا كانه اختبار صحفي على
الهواء
اعتقد انه يجب ان يتضمن لماذا تحولت من
تعاون اقتصادي الى شراكه وما هي الفروقات
ما بين الشراكه والتعاون وكيف تدرجت اساسا
يعني قد تكون العلاقه السعوديه الصينيه هي
الاحدث في عمر العلاقات الدبلوماسيه لم
تبدا بشكل كامل لعام 1990 ولكن كان هناك
تسارع في التعاون الاقتصادي وكان هناك
تسارع ما بين الاستيراد والتصدير والميزان
التجاري بين البلدين ولكن في كل ازمه تحدث
هناك اكتشاف ما بين بكين والرياضه ان هذا
البلد يحتاج الى ذاك وذلك يحتاج الى هذا
فيزيد همم عدد او ميزان التعامل التجاري
يعني اكتشف البلدان فيما بعد انهم يحتاجون
الى شراكه تعزز هذا التعاون وتقوم تلبيه
احتياجات مبادره الحزام والطريق ورؤيه 20
30 كل هذه العوامل يجب ان تكون في المقال
عدوان
خاصه
الايام القادمه والاشهر القادمه والسنوات
القادمه وما الذي ستحمله من تفاصيل هذه
اشاركه الاستراتيجيه ولكن تحدثت عن تدرج
هذه العلاقه وفي هذا الخصوص او بالنسبه
لهذا الموضوع تحدث الدكتور فرحات في احد
مقالات دكتور فرحات تحدثت عن تدرج الصين
في تعاطيها مع دول الخليج ودول المنطقه
وفي حساباتها عموما وقلت بان الرئيس
الصيني سجن همم غير في مرحله من خطاباته
من ادواته خدمه لاهدافه هذه المرحله ما
الذي سيخدمه في تقربه من الخليج من
السعوديه اولا من الخليج ثانيا ومن
البلدان العربيه الثالثه
نعم مساء الخير اولا يعني في الحقيقه يعني
هذا هذه القمم في حد ذاتها اعتقد انها
تؤكد التحول الذي يحدث في السياسه
الخارجيه الصينيه
واقترا واقتراباتها بشان التعامل مع
القضايا الدوليه بشكل عام ومع العالم او
النظام العالمي اا بشكل خاص يعني اولا
الحضور او هذه القمم تؤكد يعني في هذا
التوقيت بالذات في التطور النظام العالمي
هي رساله واضحه بان الصين لديها استعداد
للوجود همم في الاقليم هذا الاقليم يعني
منطقه الشرق الاوسط كما نعلم كان مكسور
لفتره طويله على الوجود الامريكي همم يعني
همم
وقبل ذلك كان هناك تنافس لكن الان الرساله
واضحه بان الصين لديها الاستعداد ليس
لمزاحمه قوه دوليه اخرى في المنطقه ولكن
على الاقل ان تكون موجوده لو ان لديها ما
يمكن ان تقدمه لي الاقليم في الماضي كانت
الصين تعتمد على اقليم الشرق الاوسط كمصدر
للطاقه وكانت يعني لم يكن هناك مؤشرات او
لم نلمس حضور صيني بشان قضايا اخرى او في
مجالات اخرى لكن الان الصين اولا تنتقل من
مجال النفط الى مجالات اخرى همم له مجال
همم قضايا اخرى حتى القضايا الاقتصاديه
تنوعت بشكل كبير وتجاوزت قضيه النفط لكن
في المجمل اعتقد ان الصين يعني تتجه الى
تجاوز قضيه العلاقات الاقتصاديه همم
فبالتالي الحضور الصيني بهذا الزخم في ال-
يعني في المنطقه اعتقد انه
ينطوي على الرساله واضحه بان الصين لديها
استعداد للوجود في هذا الاقليم وانها لا
تولي او لا يعني تعطي اهميه كبيره ليه
مساله العلاقه او على حساباتها مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن هذا لا
يخص الصين فقط هو يخص ايضا دول المنطقه
الا ان دول المنطقه ليست يعني مفعولا بها
هي دول لديها مشروعاتها الوطنيه لديها
تصوراتها فيما يتعلق به علاقاتها مع القوه
الدوليه لديها تصوراتها ايضا فيما يتعلق
بطبيعه المرحله الحاليه في النظام العالمي
وكيف يمكن الاستفاده منها فبالتالي نحن
ازاء طلاقي او توافق مصالح اا بين الصين
وبين دول المنطقه واقصد الدول الرئيسيه في
ال- العالم العربي لكن ما زالت العلاقات
العربيه الصينيه تحتاج الى تطوير في
مجالات اخرى ما زال هناك يعني مسائل او
القضايا مسؤوله
حتى لا نبقى في العموميات ولا ندخل الى
تفاصيل هذه الشراكه همم استاذ عدوان همم
الكل يعلم بانه هذه المرحله التي نعيشها
هي مرحله اصطفافات عالميه همم هناك
متغيرات يعيشها النظام العالمي وهنا كذلك
متغيرات يعيشها العالم سواء اقتصاديا
سياسيا وعسكريا في المجال يا سي كيف تفكر
السعوديه خاصه ونحن نعلم بان السعوديه
اولا عاشت نهضه وتعيش نزلت تعيشها في
الفتره الاخيره وعلى جانب اخر لما نتابع
او نقرا تحركات السعوديه دبلوماسيه هي
استقبلت بوتين في 2019 وفي 2022 استقبلت
لابروف استقبلت الرئيس والان تستقبل
الرئيس الصيني السعوديه الرسميه
الدبلوماسيه كيف تفكر
حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم اختبار العالم
العربي في اي اصطفاف ابدا ما عدا الازمه
الروسيه وكان المطلوب هو موقف ولكن لم
يحدث ازمه عالميه حقيقيه تتطلب الثقافات
او اختبار الدول العربيه فحتى هذا اللحظه
نترك موضوع الصفات حتى ياتي ولكن كيف تفكر
السعوديه دبلوماسيه مثل اي دوله لها ثقل
استراتيجي تفكر كيف تصافح الجميع كيف تكون
على مسافه واحده من الجميع ويعني قد تحدثت
بكل في الساعات مبكره مع قناه العربيه
اليوم ان هناك يجب ان نفرق ما بين مصطلح
شريك وحليفه الصين هي شريك ولكن لم ترتقي
بعد الى مستوى حليف والعلاقه بين الصين
والولايات المتحده والسعوديه او الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والسعوديه يعني همم كان
العلاقه بين السعوديه والصين حفيده لتاريخ
العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والسعوديه يعني منذ عام 1990 فقط الامر
اخر اشتراك الاقتصاديه لا يمكن في اي حال
من الاحوال ان ترتقي الى تعاون عسكري او
امني بشكله الكامل لاسباب بسيطه جدا
التقنيه العسكريه الصينيه لم تختبر حتى
هذه اللحظه ايضا ولا يمكن ان يكون للصين
اهداف لدخول منطقه الخليج ومنطقه الشرق
الاوسط عبر بارجات او حاملات طائرات او
مقاتلات وانما هي تريد ان تحصل على حصه
كبيره جدا من التنميه التي تحدث السعوديه
ومن يعني دعينا نقول اقتصاديات الخليج
وتحاول بناء بعض الدول في القاره
الافريقيه عبر السياسه الصينيه الاقتصاديه
المعروفه بالاقراض طويل المدى فصيل لها
اهدافها ولكن السعوديه تريد ان تستفيد من
هذه الاهداف تريد ان تصافح الجميع لن
تتخلى عن الغرب وهي تصافح الشرق فهمم انا
اعتقد هذا هو الاطار الطبيعي استفيد من
الغرب بما اريد وما استطيع واستفيد من
الشرق بما اريد وما استطيع واذا حدث يعني
انضغط على الدول في اصطفاف لازمه عالميه
كبرى وقتها لكل حادث حديث صحيح لم نصل الى
مرحله للصفافات ولكن لاكمل معك فقط بخصوص
نقطه استاذ عدوان همم لن نتحدث عن شراكه
عسكريا نتحدث في شقه سياسي عن امكانيه ان
يكون للصين كذلك حضور اكثر مما هو عليه
اليوم نتحدث عن الملف الايراني وحضرتك
تعلم بان لصين كذلك اتفاقيات مع ايران
وهناك مسالك دبلوماسيه مفتوحه مع ايران
كيف يمكن ان همم نتحدث عن مقاربه صينيه
سعوديه ايرانيه في المرحله القادمه
جميل ااه انا اعتقد سؤال مهم حدث قبل اربع
سنوات حسب نوع الشيعه طبعا وما سر
المعلومات ان الصين لعب الدور وسيط يعني
او عرض في الوساطه على السعوديه وايران
تكون وسيط بين البلدين لاعاده العلاقات
ولكن هذه الوساطه لم تفلح الصين لديها
علاقات مباشره مع ايران لدي علاقات قويه
مع عيران اذا كان هناك يعني من نتائج لهذه
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه والمؤمنه التي وقعت
اليوم قد يكون على بعد عامه وعامين من
الان يعني نشاهد لا لا نقول ضغط صيني يعني
الصين ليست في موقع الضغط بعد في من ناحيه
استثماراتها ولا قوه الاقتصاديه في ايران
ولكن قد تستخدم العلاقات والشراكه
الاستراتيجيه مع السعوديه لتقريب وجهه
النظر لمحاوله تحيد اا خطر ايران في
المنطقه ايضا في الامم المتحده المقعد
الصيني دائما مهم وانا اعتقد ان السعوديه
استفادت من هذا المقعد في في المقعد
الدائم مجلس الامن سواء في موضوع حرب
اليمن وفي كثير من القضايا فيعني الصين في
دورها السياسي مهمه جدا ولا يمكن التغافل
عنها او عن او عن حضورها ولكن لا ترتقي
ابدا الى مستوى الامني السياسي مهم
الوساطه مع الصين كمال مع ايران كما ذكرت
مهمه همم ايضا هناك تواجد غريب الهدف
المعلب منه حمايه الملاحه البحريه ولكن
الهدف الخفي منه قد يظهر بعد سنه سنتين
عشر وهو القائد العسكريه الصينيه في اا
جيبوتي وهو اول تواجد تقريبا دعينا نقول
في المناطق المشاطه للجزيره العربيه ودول
الخليج همم للصين منذ دعينا نقول حتى
نشاتها فهذا التواجد ونشات الصين الحديثه
هذا تواجد غريب قد يتبعه يعني انا اعتقد
اذا تبعه هذا التواجد ايجاد ثغره معينه
لانشاء قاعده عسكريه ثانيه وثالثه في
المنطقه هنا قد يعني توضع علامات استفهام
ان التواجد الصيني الاقتصادي ليس بريئا
وانما له اهداف بعده حتى لو لم تظهر الا
بعد 50 عاما
بعض ربط موضوع قاعده جيبوتي وهي اول قاعده
انشاتها صيف في تاريخ الحديث كما قلت
ربطها بهدف الصين الاقتصادي همم مبادره
الحزام والطريق فدكتور فرحات هل تعتقد
بانه همم الصين هدفها الاول هو ان تفعل
هذه المبادره همم ان تفتح مجال من اسيا
لاوروبا وصولا لافريقيا وما الذي يمكن ان
تقدمه السعوديه الخليج والعربيه في هذا
الاطار لتحقيق هذه الفكره
يعني اسمح لي في البدايه انه اشير الى عقب
فقط فيما يتعلق بقضيه الاتفاق الصيني مع
ايراني هذه بالفعل احد القضايا الغامضه
حتى الان وفي راي انها تحتاج الى حوار
صريح مع الصين لان هذا الاتفاق المجهول
يعني في اكثر مما هو معلوم همم فيما يتعلق
من مساله الحزام والطريق
هذه القمم وما اذا كان يمكن ان تساهم فيه
تفعيل او تسريع تطبيق الحزام والطريق في
المنطقه بالفعل الصين يعني تولى همم
يعني مساله الحزام والطريق هي احد
المشروعات الرئيسيه للرئيس الصيني الحالي
وهو مرتبط باسمه بشكل همم مباشر همم لكن
فيما يتعلق يعني فيما يتعلق بالمنطقه ما
زالت هناك بعض القضايا التي تحتاج الى
يعني مزيد من التفاهم او مزيد من التعميق
العلاقه مع الصين بشانها او النقطه الاولى
ان الح والطريق عندما طرح في البدايه همم
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط كانت تركيز الاكبر
على ما عرف به ممر الصين غرب اسيا وهو ممر
مقصص للربط بين الصين
وايران مرورا يعني وصولا الى اوروبا
ومرورا بتركيا ثم بعد ذلك يعني اندمج
الدول الخليج العربي ودول اخرى فيما يتعلق
بالمكون البري همم عندما قد هذه همم يعني
هذه المبادره وثبت مع الوقت ان ما يمكن ان
تقدمه دول الخليج العربي والمنطقه العربيه
ليه تسريع تطبيق الحزام والطريق خاصه فيما
يتعلق بفرص التنميه بتنميه البنيه التحتيه
وتعميق الترابط بين الصين والمنطقه فيما
يتعلق بالموانئ البحريه كل هذه وقطاعات
اخرى قطاعات ال- ال- البيئه وغيرها
والطاقه كل هذه المجالات اثبتت ان فرص
تسريع وتطبيق الحزام والطريق في المنطقه
همم مع العالم والاقتصادات العربيه
والاقتصادات الخليجيه اكبر بكثير مما يمكن
ان تقدمه ايران على مسارات الحزام والطريق
فضلا عن ان ازمه الايران مع الغرب
والعقوبات وغيرها من القضايا الاشكاليه
همم بين ايران والاقتصاد العالمي همم قالت
بشكل صريح ان هناك سقف ليه امكانيه
استفاده الصين من الحزام والطريق فيما
يتعلق به همم
اكبر بكثير صحيح ولكن كانت الدول العربيه
والخليجيه قادره ان تساهل تفعيل هذه
الفكره همم بطريقه حقيقيه همم فيما
ستستفيد هذه الدول
هناك فرص كبيره طبعا الاستفاده الاقتصادات
العربيه والخليجيه من الحزام والطريق اولا
لديها فرص كبيره للاندماج في المكون البري
للمبادره كل مشروعات البنيه التحتيه في
منطقه الخليج العربي بالاضافه الى يعني
ايضا الربط بين الموانئ الخليجيه
والمكون البحري للحزام والطريق يعني تعتبر
او تمثل يعني مؤشر مهم على الفرص استفاده
الاقتصادات العربيه والخليجيه من الحزام
والطريق بالاضافه الى ذلك يعني هناك
القضيه الخاصه بتنميه البنيه التحتيه
مساله شديده الاهميه لان دول المنطقه
العربيه والدول الخليجيه لديها تركيز كبير
على قضيه البنيه التحتيه وقضيه البنيه
التحتيه لم تعد قضيه اا يعني قطريه او
قضيه محليه فقط ولكن بدات تكتسب ابعاد
اقليميه لان هناك مشروعات ليه الربط
الاقليمي والربط الاقتصادات العربيه من
خلال البنيه التحتيه سواء في مجالات
الطاقه او غيرها فبالتالي هناك فرص بالفعل
لاستفاد الاقتصادات العربيه والخليجيه من
الحزام والطريق اذا خاصه اذا اخذنا في
الاعتبار ان هناك وفرات ماليه كبيره لدى
الصين ممثله في الاحتياطيات الدوليه
بالاضافه الى الاذرع الماليه المهمه التي
همم استحدثتها او يعني همم وفرتها الصين
ليه تمويل المشروعات المبادره مثل صندوق
الحرير او البنك الاسياوي الاستثمار في
البنيه التحتيه فضلا عن دخول البنوك
الصينيه نفسها في عمليه تمويل همم
المشروعات الدنيا الى المتعلقه الحزام
فرصه ثانيه فرص همم كبيره للطرفين الصين
من جهه وكذلك لدوار العربيه الخليجيه من
جهه اخرى من بين الملفات الاخرى المطروحه
استاذ عضوان هي همم
نظام عالم جديد تعلم حضرتك بانه منذ عقود
نعيش همم في نفس النظام العالمي همم على
قيمته المتحده الامريكيه اليوم هناك اصوات
تتعالى وتجاهر بمطالب تتمثل في ان يكون
هناك نظام عالمي متعدد الاقطاب هل تعتقد
بانه هكذا نموذج يخدم المنطقه يخدم الخليج
ويخدم الدول العربيه وكيف
وزير الخارجيه الاسبق عبد الرحمن الشرقاوي
حينما قال السياسه ليس ما يطلبه المستمعون
وانا اعتقد ان الحديث عن النظام عالمي
جديد لا يمكن ولا يمكن ان يطبق حتى اريد
ان نبالغ في العشرين 30 سنه القادمه
بالاسباب بسيطه مجموعه السبع حينما ارادت
حرمان روسيا من همم النظام السوفت قامت
بعمل ذلك في قال من ساعه مكالمه مرئيه بين
قاده المجموعه السابعه انتهت المكالمه
روسيا خارج النظام العالمي المالي الصين
لا يوجد لديه هذه القدره اذا اردنا ايضا
ان نحسب حسابات النظام العالمي الجديد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بامكانه ايقاع
عقوبات ماليه على الصين بامكانها حرمان
الصين من بعض التفاصيل الاقتصاديه لا
تستطيع فعل ذلك على الولايات المتحده
بالعكس الصين تتمنى من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فك بعض القيد الاقتصاديه ولهذا
يعني حتى نتحدث عن نظام عالم جديد هذا
النظام يحتاج الى قوه متحالفه تستطيع
ازاحه النظام الحالي والنظام الحالي لا
يمكن يتشكل
جماجم الملايين يعني هذه حقيقه تاريخيه
تمت بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه الحلفاء
المنتصرون هم والمسيطرين على العالم اليوم
ما عدا طبعا روسيا التي تتقلب من فتره
لاخرى فيعني لا نريد ان نتمنى ان يكون
هناك يعني ملايين من الجماجم الجديده حتى
نرى نظام عالمي يحكم همم العالم انا اعتقد
ان النظام الغربي هو الحاكم القوي الان مع
بعض الشركات مثل اليابان في مساء الاقتصاد
والمال همم تحتاج الدول المتحالفه يعني
حتى تذيع هذا النظام الى دعينا نقول عقود
او الى حروب او الى كارثه طبيعيه تزيح هذا
النظام من المشهد ولكن ما تفعل الصين وما
جعل الغرب يستفز هو محاوله الاستعمار
الاقتصادي اليوم حتى ولو لم يكن هناك نظام
عالم جديد سياسيا انا اعتقد ان هناك
النظام عالمي اقتصادي جديد يتم من خلال
الطريقه الصينيه في الاستعمار البطيء
للدول الفقيره او النامي اقتصاديا ومن
خلال مد همم شبكتها الاقتصاديه في مختلف
ارجاء العالم حتى لا تستطيع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والغرب مواجهتها الا
بطريقه العقوبات جميعا يتذكر موضوع هواوي
والجيل الخامس حينما كانت الحيل الغربيه
الوحيده لايقاف هذا الاجتياح هو همم تهامه
بالتجسس اريد ان اضرب مثال على موضوع
السوشيال ميديا جميع شركات السيليكون غالي
التي سيطرت على المشهد الاعلامي الصين
اخرجت منتج جديد فقط اسمه تيك توك هز عرش
كل هذه الوسائل الاعلاميه التي سيطره
عليها الغرب اللي اكثر من يعني دعينا نقول
20 عاما تقريبا عام 2001 تدريجيا منذ بدل
الانترنت حتى هذه اللحظه تكتب يزيح سناب
شات ويزيح فيسبوك ويزيح يعني انستغرام من
عدد المتابعين والمستخدمين فتخيل ان هذه
الشركه التي اطلقت هواوي واطلقت تيك توك
واستطاعت استعمار العالم الاقتصاديه بماذا
تفكر لا احد يفكر بهذا التنين الذي يجب
علينا عدم تسميه بالتنين النائم بل هو
التنين المستيقظ الذي بدا يتهم يعني دعي
يقول همم الاف الاميال من الكره الارضيه
اقتصاديا وبدا يفكر كيف يمكن ان يزيح
خصومه ليس بقاعفات الطائرات ولا بالقنابل
النوويه وانما بشركات الاقتصاديه طويله
المدن
يؤكد على اهميه كذلك هذه التكنولوجيا
الحديثه التي تمتلكها الصين وحتى العمليات
سبرانيه يقول بعض بان هذا شكل من اشكال
الحروب الجديده الاكيد بان الموضوع سيبقى
للمتابعه والاكيد باننا سنلتقي في نقاشات
اخرى او شكرا جزيلا الشكر على مشاركه هذا
النقاش من الرياض عضوا الاحمر الرئيس
تحرير عربيا والدكتور محمد فرحات رئيس
مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]